Arghabillahimina Shaytana Rahim Bismillahir Rahmanir Rahim Alhamdulillahiladi la yablughmidhatahul qa'ilun wala yahsina'ma ahul aaddoon wala yuaddihaqtahul mujtahidoon aladi la yudriku baadalhimam wala yanaluhu gausal fitan
Alladhilaisalisifatihatdun Mahdudun, wala Natun Mawjudun, wala Waktun Madudun, wala Ajalun Mamdudun.
Fatal Al-Khala Eqabi Qudratihi, wa Nasharar Riyahabi Rahmatihi, wa Wattadabis Sukhuri Madana Ardihi.
Wassalatu Wassalamu Ala Sayyid Alambia Iwil Mursalin, Khatimin Nabiyin, Sayyidin Al-Mumadjad, Bashir Al-Musaddak, Nadir Al-Muayyad, Al-Mustafal Amjad,
Mahmoud al-Ahmad Abul Qasim Muhammad Wa salatu wa salamu ala wa sihi alibnabi Talib ashraf al-wasiyin wa amir al-mumineen Wa salatu wa salamu ala sayed al-imamit tayyib, sahib dawatil nabawiya Wa saulatul Haydariya, wa Ismatul Fatimiya, wa Shujaatul Husayniya, wa Ulum al-Bakariya, wa Ma'akil al-Jasariya
Wal Hikmatul Ismailiyah wal Judul Muhammadiyah Sallallahu Alaihi wa 'ala alihim wa sallimhum tasliman kathiran kathira Allahumma ilma lana ila ma alamtana inna kaantal alim al-Hakim Allahumma alimna bima yanfana wa yanfana bima alamtana Allahumma inna na'udu bikamin ail min la yansa wa min qalbin la yakshar wa min aainin la tadma wa min nafsin la tashpa
Allahumma inna na'udubi ka min daawatin la yusta jabulaha wa min mon karatil akhlaq wala amal wala hawa fa'amma ba'ad yaqulu subhanaw wa ta'ala fi kitabahil kareem ba'ada aqula audubillahim mina shaytan rajeem bismillahir rahmanur rahim rabbish rahli sadri wa yasirli amri wahluruqdatamil lesa ni fkahu kawli Allahumma inni a'udubikaan adallah awudal awazila awuzal
Our Aslim, our Uzlam Aliyah.
Wa Ajhal, our Yujhal Aliyah.
Allahu Masabit Naindal Moutibila ilaha illallah.
Allahu Majal Namin Alladina Amanu Amil Salihat.
Watawa Sabbil Haq.
Watawa Sabr.
Amin Ya Rabbil Alamin.
Salam Alaikum warahmatullahi wabarakatu.
There's a Hadith which is called Hadith Gibral.
It's a very famous Hadith.
where Jibreel comes to the Prophet in the form of a man.
And he asks him four questions.
What is Islam?
What is Iman?
What is Ihsan?
And then he asks him about the signs of the end of time.
So when, I mean, you can look it up and you know, you can get all the information about it.
I'm just going to talk about Islam, that when he was asked about Islam, the Prophet replied, Al Islamu an tashhada an la ilaha illallah wa anna Muhammad Rasool Allah.
He said, Islam is to bear witness that there is no God but Allah.
And Muhammad Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam says, Messenger.
Wa tuqima salah, to establish prayer.
Wa tuqti zakat, to give alms.
Wa tasuma Ramadan, to fast the 30 days in Ramadan.
Wa tu hajjal bayt in his ta'ata ilahi sabilah.
And to perform the pilgrimage to the House of God if you have the means.
Now what's interesting about this Hadith is that rather than giving a definition of Islam, which I would have expected, Rasulullah Alaihi Salaam, he described it as a set of practices.
In other words, what he's saying is that Islam is work, right?
But what we forget is that this is not how Islam started.
Islam as a human phenomenon, it
began with an incredible experience for the Prophet and then finally culminated in a set of practices.
For most of us, Islam begins as a practice.
It never begins for us as an experience, but that's not how it began for the Prophet.
How did it begin for him?
It began with a direct experience of the noumenal realm, right?
So you have the phenomenal realm, which is this world.
This world of appearances or what we call the seen world, Halim al-Shahada.
And then there is the noumenal realm, which is the unseen world, right?
Halim al-Gaib, which constitutes the metaphysical realities like God, angels, heaven, hell, all those things.
And the Prophet experienced both in his lifetime.
He had the phenomenal experience in the cave of Hira.
And then he also had the numinal experience with his ascension, right, the Maharaj.
So in today's session, what I wanted to do is I want us to connect with both those experiences.
Sort of step in his shoes and try to understand what it must have felt like.
Because his experiences, particularly these two experiences, they set a precedent for us in terms of what Islam is meant to feel like.
We all know what it is in terms of practice, but it's important for us to understand what the feeling or the experience of Islam is as it was for the Prophet.
So that once we connect with that, then we will talk about how we can use his experience for our own benefit.
So the year is 620 AD.
Our Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam, he's 40 years old.
Socially, the culture that he lives in is very troublesome for him.
He's bothered by the behavior of these Jahili Arabs, especially idol worship.
because he had a natural disinclination towards superstitions or any kind of animism for that matter.
So he's troubled, right?
And when you're troubled, what do you do?
You retreat.
So he wanted to get away from it all.
And in order to do that, he would, he made it a habit to go to this cave within a mountain called Jabal al-Noor, which literally means the mountain of light.
And the cave itself was called Hira, which means darkness.
And I find that interesting, right?
A cave named darkness within a mountain named the mountain of light.
Anyway, so he gets into this regular practice of contemplation and reflection, which today we call meditation or Tahannus, which is emptying the mind.
The word tahanas comes from hence, which in Arabic means shirk, attributing partners with God.
In Surah Al-Waqia, Allah says, These people, they insist on committing great shirk.
So, hence is shirk, attributing partners.
In Arabic morphology,
There's something called Baba Tafaal, where you add a taa before the word and the meaning morphs into avoidance of.
So hence, as it's used in the verse, hence means shirk.
Tahannus means the avoidance of shirk.
Jannb means side or nearness.
Tajannub means to avoid somebody's nearness.
So there are a lot of words like hajud, which means sleep.
Pahajjud means to avoid sleep.
Anyway, these are all these different words that follow the same pattern and morphology.
So one day, this 40 year old man, he's busy meditating in this cave at the top of this mountain.
And just like any other day, he gets into this deep contemplative state and his desire is
this attempt to empty out forms.
That's what he's trying to do.
He's trying to disconnect himself from this physical world.
He wants to free himself from all of these forms or attachments of this world.
Now, what's the greatest shirk of all?
What is the greatest shirk of all the greatest
It's the worship of the self.
Idolatry has nothing on self-olatry.
I just made that word up.
But really idolatry has nothing on self-worship or egocentricity.
According to our tradition, worship of the self, which pretty much everyone is engaged in today, it's the most destructive thing there is for the soul.
Allah talks about these people who worship their desires and their passions.
Do you not see the one who took his own desires, his own passions as his God?
Do you not see the one that when his desire commands, he just simply submits?
Because that's worship.
So Rasulullah Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam is in this cave in deep reflection.
working on himself.
He's trying to empty his heart out of all these attachments.
And even in Chinese, you have this thing, empty your cup so that it can be filled with something new.
Because the soul has to be emptied of all forms before it can gain knowledge of the one who has no form.
Because forms, they impinge on that understanding.
And as he's doing that, suddenly he sees the horizons filled with the presence of an angelic being.
And this being says to him, Muhammad, I am Jibreel and you have been chosen as the messenger of Allah.
So he raises his head to see who's speaking to him and he sees Jibreel filling up the horizons.
Now think about that for a second, if all of us stepped out right now,
and we saw an angelic presence from one horizon to the other and as far up in the sky as we could see, how would that affect us?
How would that affect us psychologically?
How would that affect us physically?
What would you and I experience in that moment?
Would we be terrified?
Would we be horrified?
Would we be shocked?
What would we experience?
See, the interesting thing about experience is that it is not a logical proposition.
You cannot prove or disprove experience.
You can discuss it, you can talk about it, you can try to interpret it, but you cannot say whether it's true or false.
Because experience is always real for the one experiencing it.
The challenge then is to determine whether or not that experience has an objective reality or it has a subjective reality.
In other words, is that experience really a true experience or is it something that is just happening to this individual as a type of psychosis?
Because we do have a lot of people in psychic wards today speaking to God directly, right?
They will tell you that they speak to God and they can hear God speaking to them.
These people are not lying.
Because even though they are in a delusional state, they actually believe what they're experiencing.
Their delusions are very real to them.
So the prophet naturally is filled with all those human emotions, fear, shock, horror.
So he turns his face away from him.
But no matter where he turns, he sees the angel in the exact same form.
And then Jibreel says to him, recite.
And he replies, What should I recite?
I don't know what to recite.
And at that point, Jibreel wraps his wings around him and he squeezes him three times.
And according to the Prophet, this squeeze was so hard,
that he felt stifled to the point where he thought he would die.
And scholars have commented that this squeezing was a physical manifestation of a spiritual reality which was removing any and all remnants of this world from his soul.
He was being emptied out in order to later be filled with three divine vessels: Islam, Iman, and Ihsan.
And so there had to be a complete emptying out before the filling could take place.
And this is what he was seeking.
That's what he was trying to do to begin with, with that meditation in .
And also this is what the companions used to say about the Prophet that he would literally empty us out of ignorance of Jahiliyya and then fill us up with Islam.
Right?
And this is why La ilaha illallah starts with a negation.
there is no God.
It starts with a negation for emptying out, breaking false pretenses, breaking false understandings.
Then it says illallah which is an affirmation.
So every Islam always began with, every religion began with an emptying out.
And so even for Rasool Allah Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam, Islam was actually a complete emptying before it was a filling.
And this in Arabic is called Takhliya.
The Arabs say, That the emptying out must precede the ornaments.
In other words, you have to be stripped off of what is ugly before you can be ornamented with what is beautiful.
So that squeeze was meant to empty his soul out.
And then he says, then he starts filling him with wahi.
Qalaqal insanam min alaq.
Yaqra warabbukal akram.
Alladi alama bil qalam.
Allamal insanam alam yalam.
Recite.
Recite in the name of your Lord who created you.
Created man from a clinging substance.
Yaqra warabbukal akram.
Recite for your Lord is the most generous.
Alladi alama bil qalam.
Who taught by the means of the pen.
Who taught man that which he did not know.
So now, the Prophet moves into a new realm.
And a troublesome realm, I think.
Because for every human being, for every intellectual human being at least, one of the fundamental crises of religion becomes, is my object of devotion indeed a transcendent reality?
Or is it some kind of a distortion of my human consciousness?
In other words, is this experience really true?
Or am I having some kind of a psychological breakdown?
Now, how do you differentiate between a true divine experience and a demonic experience?
And this is key.
So pay attention to this because
This is the key that differentiates between a demonic experience and a true spiritual experience.
A demonic experience is always accompanied with an expansion of the self.
A demonic experience always begins with, you know, it's a very exciting, very joyful experience, very pleasurable experience, but then it always inevitably
It results in pain and despair in the end.
And you can think of anything that Islam deems haram, right?
Drugs, alcohol, sexual deviancy, smoking, any kind of overindulgence.
They all begin with a rush, an excitement, ecstasy, can't stop feeling high, euphoria, but it ends, always ends.
in suffering.
I mean, and this is not just, you know, like major things like alcohol that those end in like whatever hangovers and DUIs and liver diseases.
Drugs end in addictions, in ruining families.
Smoking ends in cancer, heart diseases.
But when the person actually starts smoking, when he starts drinking or whatever, right, it's the coolest thing ever.
It's like awesome.
That psychological high is intense, but it never ends well.
And it doesn't have to be this drastic, like food, gluttony, right?
If there is something delicious in front of me and I pig out, right?
If I stuff my face with it to the point where I can't breathe, how do I end up feeling?
While I'm eating it, while I'm tasting it, it's like really pleasurable, I'm enjoying everything of it.
But when I get that sick, full feeling, how does that feel, right?
So every kind of demonic experience, any kind of extreme is always gonna end up in pain.
This is why Rasulullah said that , the middle path is the best for everything.
So the point is that every demonic experience begins with joy and a sense of elation, right?
This expansion, but then it ends in constriction and misery.
Now, on the contrary, a true spiritual experience is exactly the opposite.
The initial experience is always incredible constriction, extreme fear, dreadful feeling, you know, the pressure of hard work, but it always ends in a sense of joy and expansion.
And this is just a principle.
It's not a
Like, it's not limited to Muslims.
Take any man who has ever achieved any greatness in this world, like Mahatma Gandhi, Mother Teresa, you know, Martin Luther King, famous painters, poets, anyone.
Their initial experience is a struggle, suffering, hard work, but their final experience is just this incredible expansion, fame, glory.
People celebrate them years after they die.
You know, they're gone.
Now, in this experience of our Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam and the experience of all Prophets before him, we find the exact same reaction to revelation.
The Quran tells us that the first divine words for Musa Alayhi Salaam were what?
Don't be afraid.
Because his first experience was filled with fear when he saw God on the mountain.
Ibrahim Alayhi Salaam also had the same experience, right?
Hazrat Maryam, the mother of Risa , terrified when she saw the angel.
I seek refuge of the most compassionate from you.
She got scared out of her mind.
And so this is something we find consistent in the Quran and also what the Jews and the Christians believe in their traditions, that every religious experience is always overwhelming, it incapacitates the self.
So when RasulAllah Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam received this first revelation of Iqra, it was a very painful process for him.
And this is what I want you to connect with.
That this is not, you know, someone who just enjoyed the whole process of prophethood.
He went through a lot of pain because Jibreel did not feed him the words that he repeated
to the Quraysh later on through this rote memorization.
What was being delivered to him were the meanings.
And these meanings were being directly breathed into him.
The Arabic word for breath and for spirit, it's the same, it's Ruh.
They come from the same root.
So when these meanings, this Wahi was being just blown into him, breathed into him, it was a very painful experience.
Imagine, just imagine being given mouth to mouth by a giant.
What do you imagine that would feel like?
Probably like every cell of your body is being taken over by this immense pressure of that air, right?
And then you have this feeling of complete helplessness while that's happening.
So even as that breath is giving you life,
It would feel like it's squashing the life out of you, suffocating you under its enormous weight.
That pressure, right?
This is why, according to the narrations, in the early period of Islam, our Prophet would start convulsing when he received revelation.
Because it was a very, very painful experience for him.
And the disbelievers would use that as an excuse to say, look, he's possessed by a Jinn, look, he's crazy.
But in his own words, in the prophet's word, he describes the process.
He says, it felt as though the message was being engraved on my heart.
Engraved, that's the word he used.
Have you seen anyone ever do a engraving?
Imagine that agonizing pain of a sharp blade carving deep inside your heart as you lie helplessly beneath it.
You're completely conscious of the pain, but you are unable to struggle against it.
Just imagine that that is how difficult this process of what he was for him initially.
But later on, it got a lot easier for him to the point where people would, they wouldn't even know when revelation came upon him.
So after the Prophet had this very first experience of revelation, this very first difficult experience of revelation, he went into a state of extreme shock.
Leslie Hazelton, an incredible author, and if you've ever read her book, The First Muslim, she beautifully portrays his emotions after this first encounter with Jibril .
She writes,
He did not come floating off the mountain as though he was walking on air.
He did not run down shouting Hallelujah and Bless the Lord, I am your prophet.
He did not radiate light and joy.
There were no choir of angels, no music from the heavens, no elation, no ecstasy, no golden aura surrounding him.
He did nothing that might seem as the reaction of a man who just crossed the border between this world and the spiritual world.
That is such a beautiful description.
See, if he had done that, right?
If he came down the mountain feeling top of the world, shouting hallelujah, that would have indicated signs of psychosis.
Because this is how a crazy person speaking to God behaves in the psychic ward.
So, he had no signs or symptoms of a demonic experience.
On the contrary, she writes, he was convinced that what he had encountered could not be real.
See, such a human reaction.
He was convinced that what he had encountered could not be real.
He thought it was a hallucination or a trick of the senses.
He thought he had been possessed by an evil jinn.
So the man who fled down the mountain of Hera trembled, not with joy, but with a stark primordial fear.
He was overwhelmed, not with conviction, he was overwhelmed with doubt.
Now, if you think about this, right, this is exactly our initial encounter with Islam.
A feeling of this constriction, that feeling of doubt.
Is this real?
Is there really a God?
Is there an afterlife?
Is there heaven?
Hell?
And then it's, you know, followed by the burden of practice.
You know, when you when you take Ahadi Sharif, right?
Look at that, that pressure you feel.
That's the same experience as he had at Hera, right?
It's that burden of responsibility.
Am I going to be able to do this?
What if I'm not able to do this?
that's expected with any spiritual experience.
That's the point I'm trying to make that it always begins with a constriction.
So scholars say that what happened up there on the mountain just the sheer humanness of Rasulullah Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam's reaction that is the strongest argument for its historical reality.
Whether you believe that the words he heard came from inside himself or from
from outside, it is clear that he experienced them.
And he experienced them with the force that shattered his sense of being.
You know, normally when people go into shock, they lose their ability to think.
We know this, right?
But with the messenger Ali Salam, it was the opposite.
He was able to maintain his focus and presence of mind.
How do we know that?
The proof of that consciousness is in what he said to his wife, Hazrat Khadija, Salam Allah Alaiha, when he returned home.
What did he say?
The first words that came out of his mouth when he returned home, what did he say?
Zammiluni zammiluni, which means wrap me up, wrap me up.
Now we know that people who experience shock, one of the first things the paramedics will do is they'll wrap them up, right?
You're actually told to wrap them up to create some sort of containment because part of the shock is a loss of the self because the outward and the inward, they crash.
That experience, that psychic integrity that we all have of the self being whole, it gets completely shattered when we're in shock because something has forced itself on the soul.
And the prophet realized that and so he asked his wife to wrap him up, subhanAllah.
So this was his first encounter with God with revelation and that feeling of intense constriction that he experienced.
And his very first human response to that experience while maintaining his perfect consciousness.
And scholars say that this is a proof that the experience was a divine spiritual experience and not a demonic one.
Now let's look at his second divine experience.
which is the night journey of Isra, right?
And that actual ascension to the heavens, which is Maharaj.
The first experience was establishing a connection with the noumenal realm.
The second was actually making a journey from the phenomenal realm to the noumenal realm.
Allah says in the Quran, Subhanalladhi, Asrabi Abdihi lailan min al masjid al haram il al masjid al aqsa
Glorified is the one who took his slave by the night from the sanctuary in Mecca to the sanctuary in Aqsa in Jerusalem.
The word Sara in Arabic means to travel in the night.
And Asra is used when someone takes you by the night.
You're not traveling alone, but somebody is taking you.
And one of the benefits of using the word night in its singular form
It's because the Arabs, it took them 40 nights to make the journey from Mecca to Jerusalem.
So the verse is emphasizing, highlighting that this journey took place in one single night.
Now this migration interestingly has two aspects.
The first was a physical aspect in which a steed named Buraq was brought for the prophet.
Buraq is defined as a steed that was smaller than a horse and bigger than a mule.
And buraq comes from the word baraka, which means lightning.
It also means baraka, which means luminous.
So this was a luminous steed that moved at the speed of light because it went according to traditions, according to the narrations, it went from one horizon to the other in one step.
So it traveled at the speed of light, which we can understand that today.
But in those days, that was imamate, right?
So even though it was a physical journey from Makkah to Jerusalem, it took place almost instantaneously.
It was at the fastest speed that is possible in the physical world, in this phenomenal realm.
But then once he reaches the mosque of Aqsa, the actual ascension, the Miraj,
That's a metaphysical journey.
It was beyond the speed of light.
It was beyond time and space.
You know, today in modern physics, we know that there are things like wormholes where you can be in one part of the universe and then you go through this wormhole and you're instantly transported to another part of the universe, right?
Thanos in the Avengers.
So,
I mean, we can understand these things today, but these were unimaginable ideas back in the day, and they were completely unthinkable.
So this was the experience of Maharaj.
The word Maharaj, it means an instrument of ascension, like a ladder or a stairway.
Araja, the root word, it means a ladder.
So the first aspect of the journey, Asra was a physical journey, even if it was at a speed of light.
But it was a physical journey.
The second one Maharaj was beyond the speed of light, where he had a witnessing of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
The Quran says, He came so close to God, he came so close to Allah until he was at a distance of two bows length with God, right?
So if you have a bow and arrow and you put two bows one in front of the other, that was the distance between him
and his Lord.
And scholars say that, I mean this Tawil and all of that behind that without going into any of that, the general description that scholars have given is that it's an, it's the two bows is an honorific expression of how close the Prophet SAW got to his Lord without breaching the Adab.
Because you know in those traditions, in that time, the closest you could get to a king was the distance of two bows.
And of course, Quran always speaks in a language that the Arabs can understand.
So Allah uses the same metaphors that they understand.
And dana actually represents a maqam.
It doesn't represent a maqan, right?
A maqam is a station.
So it represents the closeness of station, not of place because there is no physicality there.
You cannot go into the physical presence of Allah because he's not physical and he's beyond physicality.
Now, if you look at the Quranic description of this experience that he had in Maharaj, it says, Ma zagal basar wa ma taqa.
His vision did not deviate, nor did it rebel against him.
Now, we need to understand this in the context of what was happening to him.
Imagine, I want you to imagine as I say this, that he's moving through the seven heavens.
which means that he was being given this unveiling of the unseen world this numenal realm the Alem al-Gaib the unseen world was literally being unveiled for him now if we all had that same experience of this unveiling right now right if Allah removed this veil from before us the vast majority of us would just literally go insane we'd just not be able to handle it
Because it would be too much stimulation, right?
We know in our material sciences today we know that we're seeing less than a billionth of the material stimuli at any given moment.
In other words, when you and I look out into the room we're sitting in right now, we are seeing less than a billionth of what is materially there to stimulate our senses.
Visible light, it's a very small spectrum.
on the electromagnetic spectrum.
I mean, and that's how limited we are if we have 2020 vision.
So, and then we also know that the majority of the universe is dark matter.
We know that, right?
95% of the physical universe is not even perceived.
So when these scientists, when they started looking outside, they saw all these stars everywhere.
So they had to ask the question, why isn't the night sky as bright as the day sky?
Because if light travels and if all of these enormous lights are out there, right?
If the heavens is filled with these orbs of light, then why aren't they filling up the night sky the same way?
'Cause it should be like really bright all the time.
Because we only see about 3000 stars on a really clear, like a moonless night.
And what they found out is that only the light from certain stars are penetrating through.
It's literally a visitation.
Like they're visiting and then returning back.
And that's really interesting because the Quran says,
He says, I swear by the night and the night visitor.
Subhanallah, 1400 years back, the Quran is saying that the light from the stars make a journey to get here.
And it's quite literally like a guest who comes in the night.
And then it says, .
What will convey to you what this night visitor is?
The piercing star.
Now, Suqb in Arabic, it means to put a hole through a pearl.
That's what Suqb means.
You know, when you make a pearl tasbih, you have to literally make a hole in each pearl so that you can penetrate the thread through it, right?
That's Suqb, to put a hole through a pearl.
And this light of the stars that we know today, they're reaching us, they're literally penetrating and making a hole in this celestial pearl.
Isn't that fascinating?
SubhanAllah.
Anyway, I was saying that what we know about this seen world is incredibly small and yet the unseen world we have absolutely no knowledge of.
But then as he's about this journey Allah says His vision did not deviate nor did it rebel against him.
My question is why not?
Why did it not deviate?
I mean if you're traveling through this unseen realm for the first time and all of this unveiling was occurring and you were witnessing these extraordinary things, why would you not be distracted?
Right?
The answer goes back to the heart of the Prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam who had only one concern that night which was to visit his Lord.
to meet his Lord he was on a journey to meet his beloved and he was not interested in the particulars no matter how amazing they were and so he was not distracted by anything else because to him this was the journey of a lover to meet his beloved
I mean, if you've ever had that experience, you know you're not going to care about anything else in the world.
All you want is to see the face of your beloved.
You'll travel continents, fly across oceans to do it.
Because they say, everything that you can ever desire exists in your beloved.
Your beloved is the star, the moon, the universe, right?
And so the actual things don't really matter.
And this holds true in the worldly sense for us human beings.
But here we're talking about Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala so you can only imagine, right?
His heart's desire was Allah and nothing else.
And to be honest about it, if you think about, you know, everything that we are running and chasing in this world, everything we're looking for, searching for, it's ultimately our heart's desire.
That's all what this is about.
So now when he returns from that divine experience, he's completely transformed.
He is now ready to move on to the next phase, which is to be in this world free of all attachments.
Because the world is no longer a threat to him as a distraction.
He has seen the ultimate reality.
So now he can never misperceive this world.
This, in our tradition, is what's called the right understanding or the first understanding.
That we must perceive the world correctly because our lack of perception, our misinterpretation of this world is what causes pain.
And this concept is actually very dominant in the Buddhist tradition that, you know, all suffering comes from a lack of understanding of the true nature of things.
Suffering is related to desire.
Now, what I find really fascinating is that the word for desire in Arabic, which is , it also means oppression.
That's awesome.
The word for desire and the word for oppression are the same in Arabic.
Why?
Because desires oppress.
So the concept of freedom in Islam is not the elimination of desire.
It is not the elimination of desire.
Islam does not ask us to eliminate desire because that's impossible.
Right?
What Islam teaches us is to make our desire the right desire.
To desire the right things.
And for a believer, there is nothing more desirable than the company of Allah .
So these are the two incredible experiences of our Prophet, right?
The experience of Wahi through the medium of Jibreel and a second experience, which is a direct witnessing of his master without any veils, where he receives this gift of this immense expansion in his soul, taking him to the pinnacle of his Islam.
But Islam did not begin that way for him, did it?
It did not begin with a direct experience.
It began with an intermediary one, through a learning process through Jibreel .
It began with an extreme constriction of the heart, with fear, with doubts, physical pain, of absorbing the revelation.
And then followed by 13 years of persecution, trials, hardships,
only then the unveiling of the unseen realm occurred for him.
Right?
And the reason I wanted to share this with you because this had a really like an incredible impact on me as a, so I just thought, you know, I wanted to share this with you so that, you know, especially my young, the young adults in this group, I have my nieces, my nephews, and I wanted to share this because to me, this felt like
The Prophet's experience, for me, it's like an archetype.
It's like a precedent.
Because for me, this is generally the experience of entering Islam.
It's a journey for us.
We are all on a path traveling towards our master.
And the experience of Rasulullah sallallahu alaihi wasallam sets this precedence for us.
You know, just as the journey for him began with Takhliya, an emptying of the heart, just as it began with Tahanus, the identification and the detachment from elements of this world that distract us from Allah, we have to go through the same exercise.
We have to work on managing our desires, not eliminating it, managing it, channeling it.
making our desires the right desire, which is Allah Subhanahu Wa Ta'ala, right?
And we are in the process of the first journey, where we are learning, the noumenal realm is being unveiled for us through intermediaries, through our teachers, through our manasib, du'at, aimma,
These are all our intermediaries.
We're going through the same process.
For him it was Jibril, for us it is them.
Because we can't really, we can't absorb that revelation directly.
So it has to be filtered.
Right?
But this is where it all began.
And that's what Islam is, at the end of the day that's what this is.
Do you want to make this journey or not?
I mean, if you're not interested in this journey, then Islam is not for you.
Seriously.
Enjoy the pleasures of this world and actually make the most of it while you can.
That's my advice to you.
If you're not interested in taking this journey to Allah, enjoy the world.
Because it's not gonna last.
Before you know it, it's gonna be over and you're gonna be left in misery and despair.
These are principles.
We're not making this up.
This is true.
You can see this, right?
So first decide what you want to do.
I mean, when you go on vacations, holidays, what's the first thing you do?
You look it up, right?
You Google those vacation spots.
Why do you do that?
To find out if it's worth your effort.
Right?
If you're going to spend so much money, make the effort to travel all the way across continents.
You want to make sure that you'll get what you're looking for.
Right?
You ask people, have you been there?
How was it?
Did you have a really good time?
Was it a good experience?
Was it relaxing?
Did you have fun?
Was it beautiful?
Can you show me pictures?
Right?
Same thing here.
Look it up.
Look up Islam, learn about Islam.
Find out what it offers in the end.
and then decide whether you want it or not and if you don't no problem tell them that the truth has been revealed by your master whoever desires it can become a believer who does not desire it he can reject it this is Allah saying in the Quran Islam is not for everyone it really isn't
I mean, Islam is an enormous gift that has to be earned.
The company of Allah, the company of the Prophet is an incredible privilege that has to be earned.
This is not a cheap religion.
This is not an easy religion in terms of work.
It requires hard work.
I mean, if you don't believe me, study the life of Rasulullah Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam.
then look at the end of his journey, right?
Like I said, happiness is the sum total of your life.
That's felicity.
It's not the means, it's the end.
Maulana Ali alayhi salam says in one of his sermons in Najul Balagha, he says, and I'm paraphrasing, but he says something like, if you are looking for glory and greatness, look at the life of the Prophet.
did Allah elevate him in this world for his hard work or did he abase him if you say he abased him then you are a liar but if you say that he gave him glory then you have spoken the truth for his name and his efforts will shine on the sky of Islam like the sun till the end of time subhanAllah like don't know
Can't say it in any better words.
His example is right here.
Look who he is, who he became and who he has become to the world, the love for him.
But it wasn't easy.
So you make a decision.
Have you guys watched that matrix?
It's literally blue pill or red pill.
You can take the blue pill and you can go back to sleep and enjoy the delusions and shadows of this world.
Right?
Or you can take the red pill and wake up.
Disconnect from the matrix.
I mean, it's a choice.
Now, if you do decide to take the red pill, even in that movie, right, Keanu Reeves, what does he have to do once you take the red pill?
It's all work, training.
So if you decide that you want to take this journey, then prepare for it.
Don't be afraid of hard work.
Yes, Islam is a lot of hard work.
So what?
Look at a bodybuilder, right?
Look at these incredible athletes.
I mean, you think they got where they are today just by wanting to get there?
No.
Hard work, discipline, endless hours of training, proper diet, millions of reps and sets consistently done year after year.
But go and ask them if it was worth it, see what they say.
They'll say it was absolutely worth it.
So if you want this path of spiritual ascension, then focus.
His vision did not deviate.
It did not rebel against him.
Don't let the world distract you.
Don't let the temptations get you off your path.
And we will make it.
I mean, I know what I want.
I made my choice a long time ago.
To me personally, Islam was really difficult when I started, but the more I learned about it, the more I practiced it, the easier it got for me.
And I'm sure many in this group, we have elders, my parents are in here, they'll testify that it's true to be as their own experience.
I love my Islam today.
I love the experience of my Islam.
I'm not just saying that, you know that I do.
Many of you know me personally, right?
It has transformed me completely.
I mean the contentment, the freedom that I feel.
Allahu Akbar.
My Khalas are actually in this group.
I have at least three Khalas in here and others from my family.
Ask them, seriously.
They'll tell you who I used to be compared to who I am today.
Alhamdulillah.
And yes, I'll make mistakes.
I'll still continue to make mistakes along the way.
So what?
who has asked you for perfection show me one verse in the Quran that demands perfection one verse over 6000 verses in the Quran show me one verse that says you have to be perfect no never all it demands is effort right all I want from this life is to meet my Lord my prophet as a better and improved version of from when I came in this world that's all I'm never going to be perfect
I'm never gonna not miss my prayer I'm never gonna not miss a fast I will sin from time to time so what I'm not God I'm human only God is perfect what bodybuilders they don't miss a training day they don't have cheat days athletes don't make mistakes so what do they stop training do they stop playing
Did they start blaming the game?
I mean, that's ridiculous, right?
Anyway, I just wanted to be, you know, honestly share these experiences with you because they really helped me make a choice.
You know, I really clearly know what I want and I know what I have to do to get where I wanted to get and, you know, what I'll have to give up for it and I'm cool with that.
I have no regrets about it.
And this amazing experience of contentment, of just freedom, is something you can have also.
So may Allah help us all follow in the footstep of our Prophet and may He enable us to truly, truly experience the beauty of Islam because it is so beautiful.
I can't, I mean...
Alhamdulillah, I can't, you know, there's my grandfather,
used to, my mother used to say that, he said that, you know, if you knew how lucky we are to be Muslims, we would never raise our head from Sajdah.
And I never got that.
I'm like, that is such an extreme exaggeration.
Like, what does that even mean?
But today, I know what that means.
I honestly, Wallah, I know what it means.
I cannot, I cannot even express how grateful I am for
for this guidance that Allah has blessed me with.
Alhamdulillah, Abdul Alameen wassalat wassalamu ala rasuli said Muhammad al-Khatim alayhim Ajmain.
Rabbana in na semena munadi unadi liliman na aminu berabbikum faaman.
Rabbana fa faalanasu bana wa kafiranasa yatina watawa fana malabrar.
Rabbana waatina ma waatana ala rasulik